[Music]  the i-team has learned a man accused of  plowing an suv into a holiday parade in  wisconsin is also a registered sex  offender here in nevada 39-year-old  daryl brooks was arrested yesterday just  east of milwaukee police say he was  involved in a domestic disturbance just  before driving into this crowd of  people's frightening video here now  apparently he has a long criminal  history and had bailed out of jail just  days before this tragedy five people  were killed dozens hurt the victims who  died range in age from 52 to 81 years  old  waukesha has held what can be described  as a norman rockwell type of christmas  parade for almost six decades  last night our wonderful walk show  parade became the scene of a horrific  tragedy  so brooks will face five counts of first  degree intentional homicide and possibly  other charges he was convicted back in  2006 on a charge of statutory sexual  seduction in northern nevada but he was  discharged from prison in 2008.